well you you had a bit of a break
between season one and season two so was
this a character that was pretty easy to
find again is he
someone that you sort of had to remember
who he was and where you left him
no i
i think nathan is probably the most of
myself i bring to any project i've shot
just from day one reading the pilot
same
mannerism same sense of humor same
speech cadence like a little bit
it just felt like greg wrote them for me
which i know he didn't but um it it it
just felt very
very at home for me and um and i loved
shooting the first season so much i only
grew more into that greg's really great
at finding you know his his actors
voices and bringing them to to the
characters and
um
i mean it's such a great cliffhanger
that it was tough to forget where i left
off
what was it like coming back to this
virtual world after experiencing such a
hard pivot to virtual living during the
pandemic i mean did it give you a
different appreciation for the story
that this show is telling or make you
think about any of it any differently
i mean it's never been more relevant
that's for sure um
uh the interesting thing is greg is kind
of like
a
like a technology psychic or like he's
got some kind of crystal ball because a
ton of stuff that he talks about in the
show ends up coming
coming to to life and it's a little
frustrating that it takes so long for
the show to come out because
sometimes this stuff comes out while
we're editing
and you know i would say once a month
our like upload group chat sends a new
article about something that was in our
show that happens to be happening in
real life um i mean like facebook's
metaverse just called it called
themselves horizon i'm like this is just
way too weird this is straight out of
our show
it's interesting to watch your character
this season because he feels like he's
in a bit of a different place now that
he knows he was murdered now ingrid is
in lakeview and he doesn't know where
nora is so
what was it like to sort of really kind
of pull the rug out from everything you
knew about him in the first season
yeah i mean he's
he's really two different people in the
first season anyway like from if you
watch episode one and episode 10 it's
there's a there's a big change in in who
this guy was and you know part of it
maybe was was having those memories
blocked and not knowing the the
the kind of poor decisions he made
um but a lot of it was meeting nora and
and
and learning from her and growing as a
person and and
you know
kind of realizing what's important
in life um
so in season two
all of that has fallen apart um you know
he's lost the woman that he loves he
he wasn't able to tell her he loves her
he doesn't know where she is he doesn't
know if she's okay
uh and here's the crazy ex who he was
finally
you know rid of or away you know got
some space from and
she kind of owns him again and i think
you know at least the way i looked at it
was
without ingrid he's stuck in two gigs
he's got no data he can't find nora he's
kind of useless so he has to play this
game and
you know just
put on a happy face with ingrid and
pretend everything's okay well he tries
to find
nora and in the time that he's doing
that
life is happening
for nora and she meets somebody else and
you know
if they could just see each other maybe
things would be different but they can't
so
she's starting to move on and he's
starting to realize that maybe she
doesn't want to be found so
he looks at the world
and his life and has to kind of think
okay
you know i used to love this girl she
uploaded for me that's a big deal
maybe i'm indebted to her i gotta see
this through see if there's anything
there
and then nora shows up again well like
was season one in the cliffhanger that
that season had there are a number of
twists in the story before we get to the
end of season two
how much did you know at the start of
the season did you go into filming this
season knowing where things would end up
or did you have to learn that somewhere
along the way
greg was super collaborative he had us
in
to the writers room in february they had
started writing um a little bit of the
story outline before we premiered in
case it went well
um and we went right before kovitt kind
of took hold of the world
and um they talked to us about what we
liked what we thought about the
characters where we wanted to see them
go
and um
and then by the time we were shooting
which was in january of
2021 i guess does that make sense yeah
um
or february uh i would say three
quarters of the script were fully
written
and um and we had a good idea of what
you know these arcs were and so i think
we had one through five and then six and
seven
were were kind of being fleshed out and
polished and trying to decide on what
that cliffhanger was gonna be um but it
it greg's pretty adamant about us
knowing you know where we're going and
him liking to know
uh the the the season-long arc and it
helps as an actor it feels really good
and and you're able to talk about
problems or like
you know things before they're the day
of you can go well this feels a little
odd or this feels a little odd and you
can make tiny adjustments on the way
there are like back-to-back crazy things
happening in like the last two episodes
of this season
and
i'm curious just with nathan and norah
finally getting to reunite and and
reconnect
what was it like to actually have that
moment what did you enjoy about actually
getting to bring those characters
together
in a
even more real way than they were in the
first season
um that was kind of a nice moment where
i was able to
step back and look at the show as a fan
because i'm a huge greg daniels fan if i
wasn't on the show i would watch it and
be so pissed off that i wasn't
nathan
but you know i i'm a huge fan of the
actors i work with and
the writers and
i think owen who wrote episode seven
greg's son is just so thoughtful in in
his stories while still maintaining you
know such a great level of humor
um he had my favorite episode in season
one and and in season two and um
it just felt like such an important
moment between those two seasons in the
making they've never seen each other in
real life
and um i mean
literally anyone could have chemistry
with with andy she's so
sweet and charming and and and likable
so
my job was very easy i i all of the
emotions were were already there and
i just kind of
i'm a fan it was it was it was easy to
just kind of look at it as like what
would i want to see if i was watching
the show
it's really nice for them to have that
payoff especially after the very strange
trip where he's you know like hanging
around her neck
while they're walking around new york i
mean that was such like an odd
visual so it's nice to actually see them
share the same space in real life
yeah yeah i mean it literally was two
two seasons in the making and
so many close calls and
you know and in the first what is it the
second episode of season one you see you
see a head explode when they download so
it you know you don't necessarily think
that that's something that's going to be
possible
um
in in season two uh and maybe it
shouldn't have been
i have to admit i am very worried that
things are not going to end well when
the show comes back i mean there's this
very real chance that it could all
backfire
so what are you hoping for in that
regard have you had conversations i know
season three is already being worked on
so do you have any idea what happens
next
i think that the finale gives you a good
idea of where things are going i think
that little montage of where everybody's
everybody in our world is at the moment
you know kind of sets up for a pretty
exciting third season
um i think what's interesting is a lot
of times like one of my favorite shows
game of thrones
the penultimate episode was normally my
favorite episode of the season it was
everything happened in that episode and
then the next episode which was normally
episode 10 was like here's everything
that's going to happen next season
so i feel like episode 7 was our
penultimate episode
and
that's a more fun way to finish so
i'm not sure what's going to happen in
season season three but um i think we
got a little taste of it uh at the end i
don't know how many nathans they're
gonna be
um
i mean like one ends in real life one's
being rebooted from a save file and one
might be getting cloned by
allegra so or by ingrid so i might be
working really hard next season
yeah i was just like okay first his head
could explode somehow his head is
regrown then maybe it could explode
again
and then he's there's this backup file
and now is he's got a nosebleed i was
like my mind is blown i have no idea
where to go
perfect
well how did you feel about how do you
feel about the fact that the download
might not be successful that you might
have to be playing one of these other
versions of him
oh i mean that would be super fun um
i mean whether it's like
i'm reverted back to old nathan who's
the kind of the materialistic douchebag
or
um
or i have to play opposite myself which
is a nightmare but also really fun i
don't know i mean it's it's
you know there are people
much more qualified than me to make
those decisions and and i'm really lucky
to have greg you know kind of steering
the ship and
whatever he has in store i'm just
excited to be a part of one of the
scenes that stood out the most for me
this season was the one where you were
in the water and
mateo is trying to lift you out it just
i kept cracking up that scene was
hilarious what was that like to do how
do you even get through that without
laughing or can you get through that
without laughing with great with great
difficulty there was
there i almost broke a few times once
when he had my like ankles and shins up
around his head i was just like
what the hell is going on he asked me to
when when he when he pulled me one way
he's like just slapped me in the face
with your dead arms and i was like all
right man
but uh it was it was nice to have had
you know he did designated survivor with
my wife so we at least had known each
other a little bit before he totally
manhandled me in a in a diaper
so uh it was uh it was it was definitely
a
top three weirdest days of filming i've
ever had
yeah i just kept thinking that it must
be so hard to shoot something like that
because you can't have any reaction
you're not aware you have no idea what's
happening so
i it just i can't even imagine what it
must be like to have to go through that
it was very odd i had to keep my eyes
closed the whole time so all i can hear
is him struggling and grunting
and and my
legs are flying everywhere it was it's
very odd
especially for the poor new guy joining
the show to then happen in that moment
yeah it's it's an audi i mean you know
what it's it kind of makes sense with
upload it's like a nice way for him to
get into the family
just when you feel like maybe you can
sympathize with ingrid she has to reveal
that she didn't really die and didn't
really upload herself and she's just
been pretending this whole time
how did you feel about that how does
nathan feel about that i mean that's
just that was like the craziest to me
one of my favorite things is when the
audience knows something that the
characters don't and you know i love
that the audience finds out pretty early
that she is
uh hug suiting it and um
and i don't find out until that baby
um
doctor scene or baby
prototype scene which is one of my
favorite scenes to have filmed allegra's
so good and so funny and she really
she really walks that tightrope of being
able to say some horrible things to
people
and then you still love her again all it
takes is one you know one or two lines
so i love that you know nathan's really
trying to be there for her
and and finally works up the courage to
be like i can't do this anymore and
that's really hard for him you know he
hates when people cry because you find
that out in the first season
and then she says i'm hug suiting it and
it's like this giant weight is lifted
he's like
great
i owe you nothing i thought that was
such a nice moment we shot it a bunch of
different ways it was dramatic all this
and i was like greg let me just
celebrate this and he's like yeah try
one and that ended up being the one that
was like the the whoo like so happy
about it
but then you quickly find out that she
like i need her again because she's
growing my body back and now she's gonna
kill my body
um
and then you feel for her again when
she's tied up in the chair and she's
like she's so good at making you go
oh
you poor thing even though you say
horrible things to people and you're
such a terrible
terrible person
she is very extra yeah well
i appreciate you talking about it i love
this season i loved the first season so
it's always one of those things that i
was a little nervous about how season
two would be and i loved it so thank you
thanks so much i appreciate that